[موسيقى]
تهديدات روسيا النوويه بغير المسؤوله وكيف
تدعو مجلس الامن الاجتماعي طارق
تزايد الخلاف بين نتنياهو ووزير دفاعه
بشان تعديل النظام القضائي والمحكمه
العليا تطالبه بالرد على تهم بازدرائها
حوالي ثلاثه ملايين تصريح للعمره في رمضان
حتى الان
وتوافد كبير على المسجد الحرام
مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من تداعيات تصريحات
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بان بلاده
ستنشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا
المجاوره في خطوه اعتبرها حلفاء كييف
واعتبرتها انها ستزيد من منسوب التوتر
الدولي الذي نجم عن اندلاع الحرب في
اوكرانيا فقط وصف حلف الناتو تهديدات
روسيا النوويه بالخطيره وغير المسؤوله قال
ان التصريحات عن دور الحلف باي تصعيد هي
تصريحات وصفها بالمضلله الناتو اكد انه
متيقظ ويراقب تهديدات موسكو النوويه عن
كثب كما قال انه لم يسجل اي تغييرات في
موقف روسيا النووي تدفع الحلف للتحرك
وايضا تعديل وضعه النووي
كيف من جانبها لم تنتظر كثيرا للرد على
تصريحات بوتين حيث دعت اوكرانيا الى
اجتماع طارق لمجلس الامن التابع للامم
المتحده قالت الخارجيه الاوكرانيه في بيان
انها تتوقع اجراءات فعاله من المملكه
المتحده والصين والولايات المتحده وفرنسا
لمواجهه ما وصفته بالابتزاز النووي من
الكرملين
الرجاء ايضا من برلين التي انتقدت عبر
وزاره الخارجيه اعلام بوتين وضع الاسلحه
النوويه في بيلاروسيا وقالت انها محاوله
اخرى للترهيب النووي الخارجيه الالمانيه
اضافت ان مقارنه الرئيس بوتين قراره
بسياسه الناتو النوويه هي مقارنه مضلله
ولا يمكن ان تبرر الخطوه التي اعلنتها
روسيا
طبعا هذا التلويح تلويح فوت بالنووي وفقا
لتحليلات يشير الى ان الاهتمام العالمي
ابرز اسباب تهديدات بوتين المتكرره
بالاضافه الى استخدامها كمبرر للضغط على
خصومه للجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات وكذا
الهروب من المشاكل الداخليه
نووي كلمه خفيفه على اللسان لكنها ثقيله
في ميزان الحرب بل مستقبلي كوكب الارض
بين الحين والاخر يخرج الرئيس الروسي
ليتحدث عن الاسلحه النوويه موجها للكلام
الى خصومه الغربيين
في كل مره يرفع بوتين التحدي عاليا فضغطه
زر واحده كافيه لمحو بلد باكمله بل اكثر
خبراء يرون ان تلويح الزعيم الروسي
باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه ما هو الا هروب
من المشاكل الداخليه التي يتخبط فيها جراء
الازمه الناتجه عن العقوبات الاقتصاديه
الدوليه على بلاده بعد اطلاق العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا
فسيد الكرملين يلجا الى سياسه حافه
الهاويه لاجبار خصومه على الجلوس لطاوله
المفاوضات يقول مراقبون الزعيم الروسي هدد
في غير ما مره باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه
اذا اراد الغرب القضاء على روسيا وفق
تعبيره فلعالم بلا روسيا حسب عقيده موسكو
بوتين سبق ان هدد باحتمال نشوب حرب نوويه
خلال العام الماضي خاصه كلما تعثرت عمليته
العسكريه في اوكرانيا فالقوات الروسيه
تقصف المدن الاوكرانيه من الجو لكن الحرب
البريه لا تحقق الكثير من التقدم حديث
زعيم الكريم الجديد القديم عن الاسلحه
النوويه ياتي ايضا بعد اصدار المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه مذكره اعتقال بحقه فهل
سيفعلها بوتين ويلجا لاستخدام اسلحه لا
تبقي ولا تذر ام ان كلامه مجرد تهديدات
فقط لا ترقى الى مرحله الفعل بلال البشتين
العربيه
وحول فرص التواصل لتسويه بشان الازمه في
اوكرانيا قال سفير كييف في برلين اوليكسي
ماكييف قال ان النقاش العام حول السلام في
الوقت الحالي امر خاطئ مكياج اضاف ان
السلام في اوكرانيا الان يجب محاربته فيما
يتعلق ببيان السلام الذي نشرته بعض
الاحزاب في المانيا قال سفيرك في برلين
انه مجرد وسيله للاستقطاب السياسي
ميدانيا تحدثت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه عن
تضرر ما لا يقل عن ثمانيه منازل خاصه
ومبنى شاهق ايضا نتيجه انفجار في كاريسك
بمنطقه تولا الجنوبيه موسكو فيما افاد
شهود وعيان بان سبب الانفجار سقوط طائره
بدون طيار وقد اكدت خدمات الطوارئ اصابه
شخصين بشظايا في حين وجد السكان المحليون
حطاما يفترض انه من الطائره المسيره التي
سقطت
وفي مدينه باقمه حيث يدور القتال الاعنف
سيطره مجموعه فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه
الخاصه على مصنع الزوم طبعا للمعادن في
شمال المدينه وذلك وفقا لتقارير روسيه حيث
اظهرت لقطات مصوره انتشار قوات فاجنر
باراضي مصنع الزومبي في حال التاكد من هذه
المعلومات فانها ستمثل ردا على تقارير
اوكرانيه وبريطانيه بان القتال في باخمو
التراجع بشكل كبير في الاسبوع الاخير
طبعا لم يكن الدفاع عن باغ مت بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا بهذه السهوله نقلت صحيفه
البريطانيه عن مصادر عسكريه اوكرانيه
القول ان كيف تخسر ما بين 100 الى 200
جندي يوميا خلال المعارك بالمدينه ووفقا
للصحيفه فان
الخسائر الفادحه التي تكبدها الجانب
الاوكراني قد تجبر كيف على مغادره في
نهايه المطاف بعد تسعه اشهر من القتال
العنيف بين الجانبين
هذا واظهر مقطع مصور جنود روز فيزا
باروجيا وهم يسقطون الطائرات مسيره
اوكرانيا طبعا بحسب تقارير روسيه فان
القوات الاوكرانيه تستخدم طائرات كمكه هذه
المنخفضه التكلفه لاستهداف المركبات
المدرعه الروسيه دعونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
وفي اسرائيل مع تصعيد التوتر جراء خطه
نتنياهو لتغيير النظام القضائي طلبت
المحكمه العليا الاسرائيليه طلبت من
نتنياهو الرد على اتهام منظمه حقوقيه له
بازدراء المحكمه كانت منظمه حقوقيه قدمت
طلبا للمحكمه العليا الاتهام نتنياهو
بازدرائها وذلك لادلائه بتصريحات حول
التعديلات القضائيه اكدت المحكمه انها تعد
تضاربا للمصالح وطالبت المحكمه نتنياهو
بالرد خلال اسبوع فيما اكدت وسائل الاعلام
اسرائيليه ان هذه التهمه قد تتسبب في سجن
نتنياهو او في تغريمه
ويبدو ان تصريحات وزير الدفاع التي دعا
فيها لتجميد التعديلات القضائيه اثارت
ايضا حفيظه نتنياهو كشفت تقارير اعلاميه
اسرائيليه ان نتنياهو يفكر في اقاله جالنت
اذا لم يصوت لصالح الاصلاح القضائي في
الكنيسه وفي هذه الاثناء حذر مسؤولون في
الحكومه الاسرائيليه من تسرب الانقسام
الداخلي المتفاقم جراء الاحتجاجات في
البلاد الى مؤسسات الجيش والدفاع كان وزير
الدفاع دعا الى تجميد خطه اصلاح القضاء
فورا قائلا ان الخلاف المحتدم بشانه ان
يمثل خطرا مباشرا على امن البلاد
ومع استمرار الاحتجاجات تمديدا بهذه الخطه
خطه نتنياهو لتغيير النظام القضائي يبدو
ان الضغوط السياسيه على نتنياهو تتزايد من
اجل التراجع عن القانون الذي يقول انه
سيحقق توازنا بين دوائر الحكم فبعدما خوف
من عصيان في صفوف الجيش وحرب اهليه حذر
منها الرئيس الاسرائيلي يبدو ان الشقاق
امتد الى داخل حزب اللكود الذي يتزعمه
نتنياهو فبعد انتقاد نادر من وزير الدفاع
ذكرناه حول التعديلات المقترحه وايضا حول
مطالبته بتجميد تمريرها انضم نواب اخرون
من الحزب لدعوه جلنط حيث طلبوا بتعليق
التعديلات في خطوه قد تقود الى احتماليه
تقلص الاغلبيه البرلمانيه التي تحظى بها
الحكومه من المقرر ان يطرح مشروع القانون
في الكنيست للتصديق عليه هذا الاسبوع حيث
يحظى نتنياهو وحلفاؤه باربعه وستين مقعدا
من اجمالي مقاعد الكنيسه التي يبلغ عددها
120 لكن وجود معارضه من داخل اللكود القى
بظلال الشك على ما اذا كان هذا التصويت
الذي لم يتحدد له موعد نهائي بعد سيجري من
الاصل ودعا يولي ادلجن النائب عن اللكود
ورئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه والدفاع في
الكنيست لتعليق التعديلات القضائيه لاتاحه
الفرصه للنقاش والمراجعه قائلا ان طرح
التعديلات للتصويت قبل ان يتضح وجود دعم
لها سيكون مخاطره من الافضل تجنبها
المزيد معنا من القدس مراسل العربيه زياد
حلبي اهلا بك زياد صراحه مشاكل كثيره الان
تواجه ليس فقط نتنياهو ولكن حتى الكينونه
الاسرائيليه بمجملها مش عارفه منين ابدا
الاهم
بان المشهد
دراماتيكيا كما لم يبدو عليه من قبل ربما
منذ انشاء اسرائيل ما رايناه بالامس عمليا
كان وزير دفاع يلقي قنبله سياسيه من
العيار الثقيل تنفجر ولديها تداعيات كبيره
ليس فقط في قضيه التصويت على تمرير قانون
القضاء او كما يعرف بقانون السيطره على
لجنه القضاه من قبل الائتلاف لان نتنياهو
في نهايه المطاف قد يملك الاغلبيه لهذا
الموضوع ولكن عندما يخرج وزير الدفاع
ويقول ان هذا الانقلاب على النظام القضاء
في اسرائيل يشكل خطرا دائما على امن
اسرائيل وقد يؤدي الى تفكك الجيش هذا
الامر يختلف بالنسبه للحاله داخل اسرائيل
طبعا هذا كان دعما كبيرا للمحتجين في
نهايه المطاف ولمعارضي خطه نتنياهو لتغيير
نظام
البيضاء
خلال ربما ساعات سيتضح
نيه نتنياهو في هذا الاتجاه طبعا
التسريبات التي جاءت هي انه يريد ان يقيل
جلن فيما اذا صوت ضد او امتنع عن التصويت
لصالح الخطه وعمليا فيما يبدو وكانه عرض
لدفع رشوه من نوع اخر حتى دفتر الذي كان
انضم الى جلند في الانتقادات اليوم خرج
بموقف مغير تماما يقول انه سيصوت لصالح
هذا الموضوع ببساطه لان نتنياهو اخبره ان
فعل ذلك سيكون هو وزير الدفاع المقبل في
حال اقاله جالنت ولديه اوراق الان في
اسرائيل لا زالت لديه اوراق وخاصه الان
نتحدث عن محكمه تريد له ان يرد على ما قيل
من ازدراء لهذه المحكمه من تصريحات له
نتنياهو
هذا صحيح ربما يجب ان نفسر هذا لصالح
المشاهدين ما هو المقصود المقصود بان هناك
الان جمعيه حقوقيه جمعيه من اجل جوده
الحكم في اسرائيل تقدمت بالتماس للمحكمه
العليا قالت فيه ان نتنياهو عندما اعلن
الخميس الماضي بانه سيتدخل في اصلاحات
القضاء هو عمليا ازدرى قرار المحكمه التي
منعته بقرار قضائي من التدخل باي شكل من
الاشكال في تعديلات قضاء لسبب بسيط لان
هناك تناقض مصالح كونه يحاكم في اسرائيل
في محكمه اسرائيليه الاتهامه بثلاث قضايا
فساد عمليا في حال ادانته المحكمه بذلك
بالفعل هناك عقوبه سجن او دفع غرامه طبعا
هذا يضاف الى المشهد الدراماتيكي في
اسرائيل بشكل عام
المحتجون من ناحيتهم ميسون اعلنوا بان هذا
الاسبوع سيشلون اسرائيل تماما بمعنى
الاحتجاج
ات متواصله فيما ان ربما تشريع هذه الخطه
قد يتواصل في خلال ايام سؤال بس زياد فيما
يتعلق بسجن او عدم سجن نتنياهو مش من
المفترض الان هو محمي قانونيا او دستوريا
لا لا هو ليس محمي قانونيا ودستوريا الا
من هو تحدث بهذا الامر لسبب بسيط لماذا
قال ساتدخل مع انه لم يجرؤ قبل ذلك ان
يقول لسبب بسيط لان الكنيست عمليا مرر
قانون في الايام الاخيره يمنع المستشار
القضائيه للحكومه والمحكمه من
عزل نتنياهو عن الحكم لعدم اهليته اذا ما
خالف هذا الامر هذا القانون بالفعل ولكن
بالنسبه الى سجنه من عدمه بطبيعه الحال في
حال كانت هناك ادانه جنائيه هذا موضوع اخر
من القدس مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي شكرا
جزيلا لك
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
تعطل لحركه السفر في المانيا عشيه اضراب
عمال النقل وتاخر رحله جويه في مطار
فرانكفورت
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه تاخرت رحلات
جويه تابعه لشركه لفتانزا في مطار
فرانكفورت بسبب مشكله تقنيه وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه ذكرت ان المشكلات الفنيه سببها
مزودو خدمات تكنولوجيا المعلومات الخارجين
جاءت المشكلات التقنيه اليوم عشيه اضراب
مزمع في المانيا يوم الاثنين ومن المتوقع
ان يتضمن احتجاج جميع موظفي المطارات
ومحطات القطار والمواصلات العامه للمطالبه
برفع الرواتب
وكان شارك حوالي 5000 شخص في اضراب واسع
بدعوه من نقابات العمال حيث قررت تصعيد
والضغط على الحكومه الالمانيه للحصول على
زياده الرواتب لمواجهه التضخم في البلاد
نتابع
[موسيقى]
وصلت نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كما لها الى
العاصمه الجانيه في جوله اعتبرت انها
لمواجهه النفوذ المتزايد للصين وروسيا
بالقاره السمراء هذه الجوله تشمل ثلاث دول
افريقيه هي جانا تنزانيا وزامبيا والتي
تاتي عقب سلسله من الزيارات الامريكيه
رفيعه المستوى للقاره التي زارها خلال
الشهرين الماضيين قرينه الرئيس الامريكي
ووزيره الخزانه الامريكيه وزير الخارجيه
ايضا في وقت تسعى فيه اداره بايدن لتعميق
الانخراط في افريقيا واعاده تاطير
العلاقات مع عواصمها
وفي خطوه اعتبرت ضربه لجزيره تايوان حليفه
واشنطن اقامت الصين علاقات دبلوماسيه مع
هندوراس بعد ان انهت الدوله الواقعه في
امريكا الوسطى علاقتها الدبلوماسيه والتي
استمرت لعشرات السنين مع تايوان واشنطن
رغم انها اعتبرت القرار سيادي الى انها
حذرت هندورس من تبعات قرارها حيث قالت ان
بكين لا تفي بوعودها
جمهوريه الصين الشعبيه هي الحكومه الشرعيه
الوحيده التي تمثل الصين بكاملها وتايوان
جزء لا يتجزا من الاراضي الصينيه جمهوريه
دورس قطعت ما يسمى بالعلاقات الدبلوماسيه
مع تايوان اعتبارا من هذا اليوم وتعهدت
بعدم اقامه ايه علاقات او تبادلات رسميه
اخرى معها الصين تقدر موقف هندوراس
في رابع ايام شهر رمضان بلغ عدد التصاريح
الصادره عن طريق تطبيقي نسك وتوكلنا لاداء
العمره اكثر من مليونين و800 الف تصريح
فيما يستمر توافد المعتمرين والزوار على
مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي بجده اداره
المطار عملت على تحويل المزيد من رحلات
شركات الطيران الاجنبيه المنتظمه ذات
الحموله العاليه من ركاب العمره من الصاله
الشماليه الى مجمع صالات الحج والعمره
وذلك وفق الطاقه الاستيعابيه كما يستمر
المعتمرون في القدوم عبر الرحلات الدوليه
والداخليه في المطار
على كل المزيد معنا من مكه المكرمه هاني
الصبيان مراس العربيه اهلا بك هاني انقل
لنا الاجواء من عندك واخر المعلومات تفضل
نعم اهلا بك ميسون واهلا من مشاهدي قناه
العربيه في موقع اخر وفي جهه اخرى وتحديدا
عندما نتحدث عن المواقف التي خصصتها
السعوديه لنقل المعتمرين او ممن يرغبون من
المعتمرين الذهاب الى المسجد الحرام هذه
الحافلات وهذه المواقف تقوم بنقل معتمرين
بشكل ترددي نتحدث اليوم عن تسعه مواقف
داخل المشاعر المقدسه وخمسه مواقف خارج
المشاعر المقدسه وسوف نتحدث عن الفرق
عندما نطلع الان على هذه الصوره التي ترصد
ترصدها كاميرا العربيه من احد المواقف
المخصصه والتي خصصت السعوديه لنقل
المعتمرين الى المسجد الحرام ونتحدث عن
مسافه لا تتجاوز
ذهاب بنقل ترددي ذهابا وايابا في وقت لا
يتجاوز على 10 دقائق طبعا حافلات مجهزه
وكذلك طرق مخصصه لها اضافه الى كبائن خاصه
للتذاكر وبوابات
ذلك مساحات كبرى لتتسع لاكبر عدد من ممكن
من المعتمرين نتحدث عن اسطول حافلات ينقل
من هنا الى المسجد الحرام يتجاوز هذا
الاسطول اكثر من 1600 حافله موزعه على
تسعه مواقف وكذلك هناك مواقف خارج المشاعر
المقدسه خاصه القادمين من خارج السعوديه
والذين قدموا عبر المطار وبعد ذلك
يتوجهون الى المسجد الحرام بامكانهم ان
يصلوا الى هذه المحطه وبعد ذلك ينتقلون من
حافلتهم الى الحافله
الاخرى الداخليه ايضا ممن هم قدموا من
خارج المناطق الغربيه نتحدث عن المناطق
والاخرى من السعوديه بامكانهم الوصول الى
هنا في هذه المواقف خصصت مواقف باتساع
كبير للمركبات وكذلك
بامكانهم الوقوف بمواقف مجانيه وبعد ذلك
يستقلون هذه الحافلات طبعا هذا الحافلات
اوجدتها السعوديه من اجل تقليل من كثافه
المركبات المتجهه الى المسجد الحرام وكذلك
تسهيل وصول المصلين والمعتمرين الى ايضا
المسجد الحرام او تسهيل وصولهم الى مسجد
حرام هذه الحافلات التي نتحدث فيها وهي
الحافلات القادمه من خارج المشاعر المقدسه
والتي تحمل عدد او على متنها اكثر من
اعداد كبيره من المعتمرين والذي قدموا من
خارج السعوديه او من خارج منطقه مكه
المكرمه والذين يصلون الى هذه المواقف
ويصلنا لهذه هذا المكان وبعد ذلك يستقلون
هذه الحفلات التي تتجه الى المسجد
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
ما بدا كهوايات تحول المصدر دخل لفتيات
وسيدات كثيرات في مصر اعداد كبيره من
النساء اقمنا صناعه منتجات متعدده منها
منتجات رمضانيه وايضا نزول بها في معارض
تنظم خصيصا لغرض التسويق تنظيم المعارض
بكثره في مصر عاد مره اخرى
وبكامل قوته بعد توقف بسبب كورونا نتابع
[موسيقى]
بينما ينشغل الغالبيه في تامين احتياجاتهم
الغذائيه في رمضان من خلال الاسواق
والشوادر والمعارض هناك فئه من السيدات
ينتظرن مثل هذه المواسم فهم يصنعن عددا
كبيرا من المنتجات المختلفه بايديهم
ويستهدفن شهر رمضان كاحد مواسم الرواج
احنا ابتديناها كفيسبوك
للستات اللي عندها مشاريع صغيره
وبيدوروا على طريقه يسوقوا بها منتجاتهم
دي فاحنا عملنا جروب الستات بتخش وبتدخل
صحابها عشان زي ما قلت لك المنتجات عندنا
لها طبيعه كاستمايز كده والناس بتعمل
حاجات بقيتها فبتعملها ليها علاقه بمثلا
مناسبات عامه